hey everybody good news good news i know
things have been a little tough lately
what with the 20-month lockdown and the
supply chain crisis and the energy
crisis and the historic levels of
inflation
but we finally got some good news
the average price of a gallon of gas
went down
two cents this week
and the democrats are bragging about
this the democratic congressional
campaign committee d triple c
posted a graph to twitter showing a
steep decline in the price of gas you
can see the slope goes way way down
the problem is that the whole y-axis of
the graph you know on the left
only covers four cents
so it's not zero to three dollars and
forty cents it's it's
it's three dollars and thirty seven and
a half cents
to 3.41
and a half cents and then the drop is is
only two cents even though gas has gone
up by more than a dollar since joe biden
took office
this reminds me of the white house
bragging about the average cost of a
fourth of july barbecue decreasing by 16
cents on his watch that seems like a lot
now compared to the amount the gas has
gone down
pretty
pathetic but
it's the best accomplishment that they
can point to and if the polls are any
indication
the american people are taking note i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the red outlaw
who says
the democrats only argument for abortion
is no take back seas
that is actually a more articulate
version of the case that the
pro-abortion lawyer made at the supreme
court the other day
couldn't point to the constitution
couldn't point to law
couldn't make a moral argument
just said well hey they made this
decision 50 years ago and then 30 years
ago no take back seas that's story
decisis precedent no take backseas not a
very compelling
legal argument you know we got to
protect ourselves folks we got to
protect our country we got to protect
our homes which is why i would recommend
you check out ring you know about the
ring video doorbell right because i've
been talking about it for i don't know
five years now the ring video doorbell
that lets you see and speak to whoever
is at your door whether it's a pizza
delivery guy or the package delivery guy
or your mother-in-law and whether you're
in the house or outside the house you
can make a an informed decision on
whether or not to open that door might
be different for different people well
did you know ring has a powerful alarm
system
they've got an award-winning powerful
affordable home security system that you
can easily install yourself
more than just security by the way
protects your home from flood freeze and
fire as well way cheaper than the other
companies for just one
month of the other companies charges you
can get an entire year of ring alarm
with professional monitoring it gives me
peace of mind especially i'm on the road
a fair bit sometimes with the wife and
the baby sometimes without and it just
gives me
gives me peace of mind let it give you
peace of mind too this holiday season
deck the halls walls doors and windows
with the best deals of the year on the
award winning ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles to get a great deal on the ring
alarm security kit today ring.com
knowles
gas has gone down by two cents merry
christmas guess christmas came early for
you you grumbling ingrates
and uh by the way if you are having
trouble affording presents for your
family this christmas season or finding
presents even with the supply chain
crisis
why then you can just join in the novel
strategy
that appears to be very successful that
a lot of people in democrat cities
around the country are doing which is
putting on ski masks and busting into
stores and stealing everything and
the the great news about that strategy
is that if you do it you as long as
you're a member of a favorite group you
you almost certainly will not
be prosecuted for it people will just
look on as it happens and then let you
get away with all of the stuff jenn saki
the white house press secretary was
asked about this strange phenomenon of
people busting into stores sometimes in
broad daylight and just stealing
everything out of the store and the cops
don't do anything and the da's don't do
anything even the security guards in the
stores aren't really allowed to do
anything
and
jensaki was asked what exactly is
causing this spate of crimes
when a huge group of criminals organizes
themselves and they want to go loot a
store a cvs a nordstrom a home depot
until the shelves are clean you think
that's because of the pandemic
i think a root cause in a lot of
communities is the pandemic yes this is
why the root cause
of criminals organizing into gangs and
stealing everything from
toiletries to gucci handbags and
everything in the middle and television
sets and everything sneakers is because
of the pandemic
the pandemic when the government just
paid people to sit at home and not do
any work
that's that's why
because i'm sure all of these criminals
were really productive members of
society before
2021 and just they're just down on their
luck and that's why they've got to make
out with a cart full of gucci handbags
after throwing a rock through a window
right
the the problem with jen saki's analysis
here other than the
manifest dishonesty and insincerity
is if she at all believes what she's
saying and i think the democrats to some
degree do
they are taking
the material view
of man barack obama used to do this they
would say hey obama how come things are
so bad in syria and iraq and they seem
to be getting worse actually on your raw
on your watch and barack obama would say
well it's because they don't have
iphones it's because they don't have
enough jobs but once we get them higher
paying jobs and once we get them iphones
and once we get them all the gizmos of
american culture then they'll stop
waging jihad
and
it's a mistake that not only the modern
american left makes
it's actually a mistake that goes all
the way back to the foundations of
liberalism
even classical liberalism or whatever
you want to call it this goes back
centuries
it's the mistaken view of man as
primarily an economic being
right the idea that stuff
is the main thing that motivates us
that's what
most of our modern society is based on
on the left and on the right
and on the left you see this with
communism once the people's material
needs are met then we'll all live in
utopia and with capitalism you see the
all people are really motivated by is
just making more money and buying more
gizmos and having more stuff but
i don't think that's true i don't think
that men are even are
entirely or even primarily motivated by
stuff i think that we're motivated by
dignity by spirit by morality by
affection for our neighbors by a sense
of loyalty and duty to our community all
the way up to to god i think we're
motivated by a lot of different things i
don't think that we are primarily just
stuff you know i think we're stuff but
we're also spirit
and i don't think that this is going to
solve
our problems we are more than just
consumers look at the west the decadent
west which has all of our material needs
met is burning
our our countries down we are we are
collapsing
it's not because we're not rich enough
the biggest problem afflicting the poor
in america is obesity we've got a lot of
stuff
but
because we're viewing ourselves
primarily as economic actors rather than
spiritual or metaphysical actors then
we're losing sense of what really
matters
in
society
we're going kooky i mean our countries
are falling apart right now all of the
rights the traditions the way of life
that we have cherished in this country
for a very long time
are disappearing before our eyes and the
ruling class is telling us they're doing
it joe biden's co-vids covidzar went on
msnbc yesterday and was asked
after all of these measures
after two years of two weeks to slow the
spread
do you think
that we will have vaccine passports not
just to go into the restaurant not just
for international travel but for
domestic travel as well and the kovidzar
says yeah maybe
why the hesitancy to require proof of
vaccination for domestic travel that's
something that especially with the rise
of this new variant we've talked to a
number of public health experts
including some who advise the
administration uh who say that is in
their estimation the very next step that
should be taken uh to try to prevent
further spread
well we do as i talked about have those
tight requirements on the international
travel we have the workplace
requirements jonathan will continue to
look at all options and everything's on
the table we're going to look at all
options and everything's on the table of
course it is
there are a lot of conservatives and
even liberals in america who say oh no
that couldn't happen here we're not
gonna
take off the tinfoil hat alex jones okay
we're you're not gonna have to show
your passport to get on a domestic
flight you're not gonna be just locked
in and quarantined in your state or
hometown
because you don't want to take the
fouchyache for the virus that poses very
little threat to the vast majority of
people
it's already happening
it's happening in canada right now
canada is passing these rules look at
what's going on in australia we played a
clip yesterday of a news report that
some men tried to flee
a quarantine covid camp
in in australia and they basically sent
in the marines there were cops
everywhere looking for these fugitives
who escaped the prison camp that they
were in
to prevent them from breathing the same
air as other people
it is happening
right now
the only reason that you think it can't
happen is because of a failure of
imagination and this is something we
mentioned it a little bit yesterday this
is something that the right needs to get
better at understanding
the left has no
failure of imagination
the left
has gone from
the democratic presidential candidate
in 2011 all of the democratic
presidential candidates
barack obama hillary clinton all the
ones before them joe biden then the vice
president
them saying that marriage is a sacred
union between a man and a woman man and
a woman which are hard and fast
sexes
that cannot be changed
we went from that
10 years ago
to marriage is completely redefined sex
is completely redefined for the purpose
of the civil rights act and there's no
such thing as same-sex bathrooms
increasingly at any institution in
america
the left did that in 10 years they
fundamentally
redefined reality
and convinced basically the whole
country to live in a delusion
ten years ago what were the
conservatives saying oh come on some of
us were saying this is a slippery slope
here's what it's going to lead to but a
lot of people on the squishy side and
the moderate side and even the moderate
liberal said oh come on that's never
going to happen
it's never going to happen
but it is and i think conservatives need
to be a little more imaginative too
especially on roe v wade we've been so
narrow we've said all that we're going
to do on roe v wade is overrule the case
and then maybe at that point you know
it'll go back to the states and we're
just going to leave it there no we're
not we want to ban it throughout the
country we can ban it throughout the
country we can do it
don't learn a lesson from the left these
the left has taken
so much more power than you ever thought
possible over the past year as a during
the covid
crisis and more broadly over the past
half-century why can't we do that
too
part of the reason we can't is because
we don't have a lot of physical assets
and when you want a physical asset
you've got to check out
acre gold get
physical gold
i know when i say that it sounds like
i'm paris hilton just just wearing one
of those tank tops that says stop being
poor you know get physical gold michael
you get physical physical gold's
expensive what if i told you you can
start getting physical gold for as
little as 30 a month you'd probably call
me a liar but hold on acre has figured
out how for just 30 a month you can
subscribe to their gold bars when your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars they discreetly ship acre gold
to your house
if you want to up the ante you can
subscribe to their new 100 a month 5
gram gold bar which is terrific acres
letting you invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
they keep you updated on your gold stash
every month and then they'll ship when
you hit the price threshold
it's a really great way to start getting
involved in physical precious metals
which i've loved investing in and
especially acre gold go to
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
this url because acres giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that's getacregold.com
knowles dr fauci
the high exalted
leader of america and the world
is continuing to run the show joe biden
actually made a joke about this
yesterday he was do we have the clip joe
biden was talking about how how he sees
dr fauci more than he sees his wife and
he was asking hey who's the real
president here
i've seen more
of dr fauci that i have my wife we kid
each other but
they look who's president fauci
but all kidding aside i i sincerely mean
it all kidding all all kidding aside i
sincerely mean it i sincerely mean it
too joe biden yeah dr fauci is the
president he's got more power than you
do
it is much more likely that you will be
thrown out of your job joe biden than
the doctor fought you will seven
presidents have come along dr fauci has
remained
all right and he'll probably remain into
the next one too so
in these jokes there's a lot of truth
and dr fauci is still running the show
he was asked yesterday about these
requirements so hold on you're going to
require proof of vaccination at least
for some air travel for anyone who wants
to get into the country the omicron is
threatening the entire world all cower
and fear from the omicron
hey what about all those illegals
pouring across the border
as you advise the president about the
possibility of new testing requirements
for people coming into this country does
that include
everybody
the answer is yes because you know that
the new uh
the new uh regulation if you want to
call it that is that anybody and
everybody who's coming into the country
needs to get a test within 24 hours of
getting on the plane to come here what
about people who don't take a plane and
just these border crossers coming in in
huge numbers
that's a different issue for example
when you're talking we still have title
42 with regard to protection at the
border so there are protections at the
border that you don't have the
capability as you know of somebody
getting on a plane getting checked
looking at a passport we don't have that
there but we can't get some degree of
mitigation
this is great stuff from peter ducey
he's got a lot of wins in the white
house briefing room but this one was
great because he just lured fauci in
he said so dr fauci
you're telling me that these new testing
requirements are going to be
for everybody
absolutely peter they're for everybody
for every single person because omicron
is a big scary thing and we gotta stop
it so everyone has to submit to these
new rules
okay
what about the thousands of illegals
pouring across the border every single
day
well that's a different issue
that's a different issue
there's like a million of them coming up
more than a million of them
i think in august there were more than a
million illegal aliens who poured across
the border that we're not really
processing and it's all haphazard and a
lot of them are not getting caught
more than we're going to have two
million people pouring across the border
this way so you're saying you're saying
that for the
i know let's say million legal
immigrants who come over they need all
the testing they need all the
requirements let's say for the countless
millions of travelers that are coming
back and forth
testing requirements heavy screening
but
the two million foreign nationals that
we know absolutely nothing about from
impoverished often failed semi-failed
states
that it doesn't matter no big deal
yeah that's a different issue peter
i think he's giving away the game here
okay these rules are completely
arbitrary
they have very little to do with public
health
they have everything to do
with controlling
you
they don't really believe this stuff
joe biden the other day i was going to
get to this later but i guess it really
fits in now joe biden the other day was
caught
in a store that required masks
walking around without a mask on there's
a clip of it there's a clip you can
actually see being filmed
through
a glass doorway that says required face
covering like right next to it you see
joe biden walking around without his
face covering on
and here's a here's another gotcha video
well it's a gotcha video for a purpose
because yeah i think that the required
face covering is bs when i see it in
stores i don't follow it when i'm
walking around an airport i don't follow
it i don't pay any attention very rarely
does anyone bother me because no one
takes this seriously including and
especially the people who are forcing
these rules on you
but they're still going to force them on
you
because it's an arbitrary exercise of
power and their power has grown
immeasurably over the past two years and
it's going to continue to grow and
you're not allowed to ask any questions
about it speaking of things you're not
allowed to ask about
whoopi goldberg
is very upset
by the prospect of overruling roe v wade
and planned parenthood bkc and she took
to her panel of cackling hens on the
view
to voice
her
main arguments against
the very real
possibility
that roe will be overturned
do any of you
men have any eggs or the possibility of
carrying a fetus how dare you talk about
what a fetus wants you have no idea
now i'm
i'm fine if you disagree with abortion i
have no problem with that my problem
comes when you tell me
what i need to do with my doctor and my
family how dare you
so a lot of confusion and problems with
whoopi's pseudo argument here the fir
the first one is she just hasn't caught
up to this because she's a liberal from
decades ago and not a liberal from today
meaning she still thinks that the
argument
men can't have babies and so men can't
have an opinion on abortion she thinks
that still is coherent in the new
leftist view of the world but the new
leftist view of the world is a
transgender view of the world in which
we are told that men can have babies and
can have a uterus and do have eggs so
that part is going to fall flat with
some of the younger viewers but the
cackling boomer hens who are watching
the show they will they will love that
then
she moves on and she does this thing
that liberals do and i bet it's sincere
but it's so stupid which is she says
look i have no problem
okay if you oppose abortion that's fine
that's totally i'm so open-minded i
respect your opinion
but the minute that you
do anything about that the the minute
you let your view of abortion affect
anything in your life or the outer world
then i've got a big problem with it
i don't i don't mind if you have that
view so long as you keep it trapped in
your head and never never allow that to
uh to express itself in in public life
how dare you
men
and pro-lifers how dare you how dare i
how dare i i will tell you how i dare
i am a citizen so i have rights at least
in theory to
participate in the government of this
country i have a brain i have faculties
of reason so i can tell that a baby is a
baby that a baby is a unique
human life from the moment of conception
and i have a conscience
at least some something of a functioning
conscience
so i know that it's wrong to kill
innocent humans
that is how i dare
those three things
self-government the ability to perceive
the world with at least some degree of
accuracy
and the ability to make moral judgments
that's that's the same way that whoopi
dare make some arguments
except
she is denying my right as a citizen she
is neglecting
and trying to deny the
scientific reality of the baby
and she is
obtusely ignoring the moral reality of
killing a baby
that's how now there's
kind of a deeper
aspect to whoopi's stupid remarks which
is
she says how do you
know what the fetus wants
right the fetus the unborn baby is not
conscious
that the baby could not
tell you what the baby wants like this
morning i was having breakfast with my
baby my baby is almost 11 months old but
he's still not really talking he says
mama and dada and he didn't like what we
had for breakfast and all he wanted to
do was eat blueberries
i wish that i could ask my little baby
hey little baby what what do you want to
have for breakfast instead but he can't
articulate his wands
and he's an 11 month old baby
really a 20 month old baby when you
factor in the nine months that he was
gestating so surely a six month old baby
in the womb can't articulate what it
wants so how do you know what the baby
wants how do you know the baby doesn't
want to be murdered in the womb and then
scooped out by some psycho doctor how do
you know that
i actually do know that the baby doesn't
want that
the way that i know that is because in
my understanding of the world which is
the traditional understanding of the
world that crafted our country and our
entire civilization
man has a proper end
there is a purpose to life
there is
the leftist year's tumbler is for
drinking leftist tears out of
delicious the leftist tears tumbler is
not for hitting a baseball the leftist
tears tumbler is not for writing a novel
that's not its proper end and man has a
proper end too and society has a proper
end too and we can know actually what is
good for people and we can know what
leads to flourishing and we can know
what is just and right
and in the radical subjectivist world of
whoopi goldberg and i don't mean to just
single at her and the view and all these
libs who are making these arguments you
can't know the proper end of man and so
it's all just willfulness and if we want
to kill the baby how dare you tell me
that i'm not allowed to pursue my will
you can remember a time when people were
not this morally stupid but but it's
hard to remember which is why when you
want to preserve your most cherished
memories
i would recommend you check out paint
your life one of my most cherished
possessions
is a painting of paint your life
at paintyourlife.com you can have an
original painting done by a world-class
artist done by hand from any photo or
multiple photos even at an incredibly
affordable price
i was skeptical i figured the quality
would be terrible and there was no way
you could you could actually get a
beautiful work of art from a service
such as this and i was dead wrong so the
first time i had one done for my
stepbrother's wedding and i got it it
was so unbelievable that i was angry
that i was giving it to him so then i
had one done myself it's hanging in my
living room it's absolutely beautiful
the artists work with you every step of
the way a wonderful way to preserve a
memory of a loved one who's no longer
with you a pet a special place have it
done it's absolutely beautiful it's a
work of art to enrich your life for
generations at painterlife.com there's
no risk if you don't love the final
painting your money's refunded
guaranteed right now is a limited time
offer get 20 off your painting which is
incredible plus free shipping to get the
offer text michael to sixty four
thousand that's m-i-c-h-a-e-l texted to
sixty-four thousand
text michael to sixty-four thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most i was thinking about
this this dobbs case which is going to
dominate our political discourse
all the way up through the midterms
probably no matter how the case turns
out especially if they overrule roe and
casey this is going to be a dominant
issue at least in the messaging of the
campaigns if we fail to overrule roe and
casey probably the right wing is going
to say that the conservative movement is
a failure and and they're going to try
to create something from scratch but
this is going to dominate
i thought why
why are we always speaking past each
other here and why
why does the pro-abortion side
why does the pro-abortion side ascribe
such bad
intentions to the pro-life side that we
hate women and we're misogynists and all
this
whereas the pro-life side i think just
believes the pro-abortion side is
deluded and has been led astray by satan
right it's usually through their own
ignorance i was i supported abortion for
my teenage years until
trying to remember when i got woke on
abortion i was probably 20 or 21 i was
having lunch with a bioethicist and she
started to convince me that my arguments
were insane and i started to see the
light so i understand how people can be
on the pro-abortion side
i think the hardest thing for
pro-abortion people to get about the
pro-lifers
is that
we treat abortion with both more gravity
and less gravity than they do
what i mean by that is
we treat it obviously with more gravity
because we recognize the enormity of the
crime and sin of abortion
but we treat it with less gravity
because we tend to believe in god we
tend to believe in jesus we tend to
believe in the unfathomable mercy and
grace of god
by which you can be forgiven even for so
enormous of sin
and the libs
generally deny that what what the libs
have done and especially in the case of
abortion is replace the christian moral
vision christianity which has prohibited
abortion from the first century
going back to the very earliest days of
the church you see it in the dwca the
earliest catechism from the second
century uh they've replaced the
christian world vision
with their own willfulness right instead
of thy will be done as you say in the
our father prayer the the libs say my
will be done this is this is like in
milton satan
in in john milton wrote paradise lost
and his character of satan is cast down
into hell and he says well it's not such
a big deal who cares if i lost heaven
the mind is its own place and can make
a hell of heaven or heaven a hell it
doesn't matter that i'm in hell right
now it's just the mind it's all just in
the mind and so i am going to craft my
own reality sound familiar i'm going to
craft i'm going to deny the reality in
front of me i'm going to
construct my own reality and it doesn't
work everywhere milton's satan turns is
more wrath and more despair it doesn't
work when people deny
the reality
i'm a if i'm a man i'm a but i'm really
a woman i'm and i am you i i who are you
fooling who are you trying to convince
the more those people who were
protesting for abortion the other day
who were screaming and shrieking and
taking
either real or pretend abortion pills
and yelling and shouting pulling their
hair out did they look happy did they
look contented did they look like they
believed the nonsense that they were
spewing no not at all and and
i think what motivates their fear
for of acknowledging moral reality is
they fear that by acknowledging moral
reality they'll have to face their sins
which is true and they're going to have
to suppress some of their base desires
their disorder desires which is also
true and they think this is going to be
a big burden and so they just keep their
heads in the sand
but the irony is
it will relieve your burdens if you
acknowledge reality
obviously on the issue of abortion but
even
beyond that even on the issue i don't
know sexual confusion or political
confusion
i think a lot of people feel guilty that
they had abortions because a lot of
people have had abortions and they think
i can't become pro-life because that
will mean that i have to face up to the
fact that i killed my kid
and i could never be forgiven for that
but the thing is you actually can be
forgiven for that
and in order to be forgiven for that you
need to have some sense of the sin and
you need to repent
the irony is that you are already
carrying a heavy burden all of these
people are by the weight of their own
sins
okay and they have no
prospect for
atonement until they and for absolution
until they until they face up to that
but if you do face up to that
it can all go away
this is when when jesus says in the
gospels he says my yoke is easy and my
burden is light that's what he's talking
about
and it's a it's a misunder i wish i wish
they could get it through their heads
because they're causing themselves and
the country a lot of undue
pain
speaking of weird sex stuff did you know
that like everybody is gay now did you
know like every single person not just
every single person in the country
that's not quite true but gen z
and the people coming after them are
super
duper gay and all the other like lbt all
of them
pascal emanuel gobre from the ethics and
public policy center just posted this
graph from statista
shows in 2014
uh the percentage of the population that
identified as lgbt
you saw it was
little
like somewhere around two percent for
the
silent generation born before 1946
somewhere around two and a half percent
for baby boomers somewhere around maybe
three percent for gen x and about six or
seven percent for millennials
okay all right fair enough
then 2017 they took the same snapshot
remained about the same for the silent
generation of the boomers in gen x but
it went up from millennials went up to
like eight percent
then they're doing that now
stays about the same for
silent generation and gen x and the
boomers
goes up even more to like 9.1 percent
for millennials
15.9 percent
for gen z
i'm not denying that there is some
uh potentially natural basis for
sexual desires and things
human beings are complicated it's a
fallen world everyone's got some strange
sort of uh aspects to their psyche and
especially sex is so important
to human nature
but there's got to be like some kind of
social factor here right
unless alex jones is completely right
and there's just something in the water
and they're turning the frickin frogs
gay and they're turning the frickin
zoomers gay clearly there is some kind
of social
philosophical psychological spiritual
factor
going on here
and i pointed out not to castigate
anything or anyone just to point out
the conservatives were right when when
the conservatives said this is a
slippery slope and you know these kinds
of
uh sexual ideologies are going to spread
throughout the society and then the lib
said that's not true and that's
ridiculous and what are you talking
about
it it was true we were we were right
society
is never neutral and this is a lesson
not just
for the libs to learn this is a lesson
for the libertarians to learn as well
and some of the conservatives who want
to say well look i'm going to do me you
do you
what you do doesn't affect me
everyone should just do whatever they
want as long as it doesn't scare the
horses in the streets
it's not how it works
we live in society
we develop based on other people
very few people in the history of the
world have ever lived alone in the woods
we live in society and the way that
other people behave the way that other
people
structure their desires even are going
to affect everyone else
and that's why these problems are not
just individual and they're not even
just cultural to be addressed by the
private enterprise they're political
they're properly political as well and
to answer whoopi goldberg's question how
dare you espouse an opinion about this
how dare i because i got a brain and i
got a conscience and because i am a
citizen darling
speaking of confusion i would recommend
you go check out
johnnythewalrus.com johnny the walrus is
matt walsh's
masterpiece children's book
about a little boy who thinks that he's
a walrus go check out johnny the walrus
today also if you haven't already you
should go check out the new merch store
over at dailywire.com
shop
right now while you're there you can get
your hands on a let's go brandon trucker
hat i think i have one oh yeah i do so i
got someone dropped this off the other
day the let's go brandon trucker hat
this has a flat brim i feel like i'm a
rapper they've got the do not comply
t-shirt
right now order in time for christmas
get a sweet discount on those daily wire
original collections that's
dailywire.com shop go check it out
immediately we will be right back with
the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question from
nick oh no
hi michael nick here but not the nick
you're used to thank goodness i'm glad
to hear that
there's that nick who writes in with a
lot of strange questions uh okay this
nick says honestly i think that nick is
just drew clavin trying to troll you
very possibly to my question
i have been unhappily married for years
i'm good at putting on a facade and
hiding my unhappiness from everyone i
find myself leaning closer and closer to
divorce without going into the nuanced
details of my marriage
would you say that unhappiness with how
i'm treated in my marriage is enough
grounds for divorce
no it's not
it's not
you're asking a catholic this question
so something tells me you have an
inkling of what i'm going to say because
the catholics
say no divorce don't get divorced
some marriages are not legitimate
marriages in the first place which is
why you can have annulment
investigations
in some cases it is prudent and even
desirable you know it would actually be
a good thing to have a kind of
separation but divorce itself is a no-no
you're not allowed to do it and i
certainly wouldn't get divorced over
this issue of unhappiness
unhappiness what does that mean i have
no doubt maybe you're being treated
poorly in your marriage
and you say
look i'm very good at hiding it
but i'm going to leave my wife what do
you mean it doesn't sound like you're
very good at hiding it you're not going
to be hiding it very well when you leave
your wife and family are you
i don't think so i think it's good to
not complain all the time i think it's
good
to
just deal with it and grow in patience
patience is a virtue
but i don't think it's very virtuous if
the end end game of that is you're just
going to leave your family i don't mean
to make light of you having a difficult
marriage some people do have difficult
marriages maybe you're being
disrespected maybe that's because you
you are not doing something right maybe
it's because you're not leading your
household in the right way maybe it's
because you just got a bad wife and she
isn't dealing with her own problems i
don't know what i would recommend is
marriage counseling obviously
what i would recommend too at a more
basic level
is i would do the marriage counseling
but at a more basic level i think you
and your wife ought to be honest about
these things and i don't think you
should just hide everything up i think
you do need to communicate and you need
to answer a really basic question
what is marriage
maybe you guys have different views of
what marriage is and that's a big
problem and that can really harm
marriages when you go into it not not
really having the same idea of what
marriage is
my view of marriage is that it is
indissoluble it is an indissoluble bond
and when i get under my wife's skin
she can't divorce me she can murder me
she is more likely to murder me than to
divorce me because we have the same idea
of what marriage is
but today for a lot of people i think
marriage is just something you do and
you maybe you don't even share bank
accounts and maybe you don't i don't
maybe you don't share all that much
stuff and maybe she doesn't take your
name and
maybe you'll split up at some point when
you don't like each other anymore that's
a kind of modern view of marriage now
marriage marriage the very basic level
used to involve sexual difference now p
some people understand marriage not even
to involve that
so i think you've got to answer what is
marriage
and i would recommend
is it matthew chapter 19 that there's
that
i hope i'm not getting the chapter wrong
but uh the chapter in the gospels where
christ describes what marriage is that's
a good place to start
and uh i would i would settle on those
things and i would communicate and i
would lead your household your your wife
is called to follow you
right now a lot of modern feminists
don't like that how dare you suggest a
wife obey or submit or be subservient
how dare you patriarch
the man is called to love his wife
and sometimes the wife doesn't want to
follow the husband
a lot of the time probably and sometimes
the husband doesn't want to love his
wife but that's what we are called to do
and we ought to do it from scott
last sunday i was unfortunate enough to
be at a waukesha christmas parade with
my young family and my parents
i had been to or been a participant in
this parade dozens of times and to
suffice suffice it to say this year is
one that i obviously won't forget i'm
writing to you however to get your
advice on how you would proceed if you
were in my shoes there are a lot of
things about what happened that have
frustrated me
many of which you and your colleagues
have spoken about over the last week but
for the first time in my life i have
true hate in my heart pure white hot
hate for the man behind that wheel i
watched him tear down the street with no
concern for human life i watched his car
fly within a foot of my three-year-old
son and continue on his path of
destruction before i could even react to
grab him the logical part of my brain
knows that this hatred only serves to
hurt us and never him
he and i will never be face to face if
justice serves he'll rot in jail for the
rest of his life
so in my shoes what would you do to cure
yourself of this feeling and move on
scott from walk show well you understand
the problem and i'll put the problem in
a really blunt way
you can't go to heaven hating people
you can't do it you can't it's not
possible
and so
unless you want to
burn in hell for eternity
uh and and say well at least i've got my
hate
at least i've got my resentment at least
i've got my wrath unless you want to do
that then you have to fix this problem
one way to do it is this i can't imagine
my reaction if i were there and my sweet
little buddy you know were a foot away
from getting mowed down by this
psychopath
black nationalist terrorist
i would probably be pretty
pretty pissed off too
the other side of that is
i would probably get down on my knees
sobbing in gratitude to the lord my god
for saving my son
who was
within 12 inches of being mowed down by
this
person right i think that obviously
there is a component of wrath and just
anger
but the flip side of that is gratitude
i'll give you a much
much less dramatic example of this there
was one time some years ago right right
before
my show i think it might have been right
before the blank book i was in los
angeles i got a slice of pizza
i went from the office got a slice of
pizza i was walking across the street i
was crossing ventura boulevard right in
the middle of traffic i would never go
to the traffic light and i was walking
across to my cigar shop there
and as i'm walking in you know ventura
boulevard there's ton of traffic all the
cars are stopped so i start walking in
between the cars and some jerk in a bmw
decides to get into the turn lane and
gun it like 60 miles an hour down the
turn lane so he can skip all the traffic
and make a left or wherever he was going
on the street
no one sees him the cars are too packed
i'm walking out
before i know anything i see this car is
coming
i'm holding a briefcase my briefcase
goes flying up in the air this guy's
mirror goes flying off of his car
he screeches to a halt
people pour out of their cars including
this guy who looks completely blanched
white in the face
and i'm still standing up
because the briefcase was an inch in
front of me and the briefcase caught the
car
if i had left that pizza shop
one second earlier i would have been
smushed
certainly before my show i think before
my blank book before anything that would
have been it
and this guy was going fast i don't
think i would have really recovered
very well if at all from this
and so in that instance you could say
you crazy uh gonna jumped on this guy
and just started beating the life out of
him or
you think oh
thank you lord appreciate that that was
a nice bit of grace and we recognized
there before the grace of god go i
you've done plenty of terrible things in
your life probably you never mowed down
a parade of people but i don't mean to
be glib about it but but you have done
bad things in your life and uh
and in the course of justice you know
remember
if justice be thy plea consider this
that in the course of justice none of us
should see salvation so i would be
grateful for where you are
i would uh
recognize that people who commit crimes
do
do harm to other people and immense harm
to themselves and uh
we have to pray for our persecutors and
that's just the way it goes from sarah
dear michael i would love some advice
from a smart put-together guy such as
yourself go on
go on stop it go on i'm a woman in my
late 20s and live a pretty good life all
things considered i like my job for the
most part
but i feel like i'm not fully happy with
what i'm doing i have friends and enjoy
life but feel a little lost and don't
know exactly what i want to do with my
life specifically work i know you'll
probably say go get married and have
babies but i am certainly not ready for
that stage in my life but would love to
to know how you figured out what you
wanted to do with your career and how i
can find that clarity
sarah
sarah you called it
you should go get married and have
babies you should you should no michael
i'm not ready for that i'm only in my
late 20s
sarah come on what are you waiting for
you're when i'm in my early 30s i'll be
when i'm in my late third when i'm in my
early 50s i'll be ready come on so what
are you talking about i'm not saying you
necessarily have to get married you
could discern a religious vocation
you could become a nun
you could
uh engage in and begin the process of
consecrated single life plenty of people
do that it's
these days it's not really talked about
in society but you could do that
marriage is not for everybody but what
i'm saying is you need to do something
your problem that you're describing is
that you just feel like you're floating
you just feel like you're not going
anywhere you're not you're just kind of
huh it's all everything's fine my job's
it's good i like my job i like my
friends but i'm not i'm not doing the
next thing i'm not moving to the next
level i'm not i'm not
going anywhere
and michael don't tell me to go
somewhere that's what you're saying
you're saying
hey i'm just floating and i don't know
what to do next don't tell me to do
something next i am telling you to do
something next
cause if really if all you're asking me
is michael how did you figure out how to
advance
in your career from where you were where
you were happy to where you are that
you're now happier i think i don't know
like you know do spreadsheets better or
whatever right
you know yeah do your job better and
you'll get a promotion and you're going
to be in the exact same position that
you are right now
i'm not ready to move to this next stage
of my life where i'm committing to get
married and do anything i'm only in my
late 20s what are you talking about look
i did it i got married in my late 20s i
wish i got married much earlier
you think you're going to lose all your
freedom you're not you're going to gain
freedom you think you're going to lose
all your opportunity you're not you're
going to gain opportunity
when you get married it's a commitment
to another person it's also a commitment
to society
you know it's very actually pope francis
talked about this the other day he said
it's very hard
to move from
the fun of falling in love to a mature
love
this is true with people
this is true of society
it's true of your career this is true of
this is true of your god sometimes
we like falling in love and then it kind
of fizzles six months later and then we
swipe right and just keep doing that you
do that into your late 20s and your 30s
and then okay then it kind of wears off
doesn't it
move on move on to the mature love sarah
you can do it do not be afraid fear not
you can do it you'll be a lot happier
from joe almighty professor koffe had a
question for you that i'd love to get
your take on i'm a parent in california
my son's teacher asked that i provide
her with photos of each year since my
son's birth
for an activity in which my son will
hold a globe
and walk around the sun
the sun and seasons blanket
while he's walking around the sun the
teacher and other students will be
singing a particular song
can't decide if this sounds like some
new age weirdness or if i'm being too
paranoid any thoughts on this thanks for
everything i love the show viva koffe
well it depends on what the song is okay
i'll put it that way
if the song is some weird prayer to gaia
or some like weird pagan goddess or
something then yeah i guess that's kind
of new age and you shouldn't do it but
it sounds to me like what the project
might be is you're just
the students have all these pictures
from every year of their life and
they're
describing the revolutions around the
sun and they're understanding it in
terms of how they're getting older and
that seems perfectly reasonable to me
and perfectly interesting so i would uh
yeah i i think it's fine figure out what
the song is first you got it you know
the devil's in the details from kyle to
the best dressed host of the daily wire
stop it your dress shirts and sport
coats always look great and i was
wondering where you buy them so i can
pick some up as well thank you for all
your hard work thank you for the
question i'd love to give you the answer
but the clothing companies that provide
a lot of my wardrobe do not yet
subsidize this show they don't yet
sponsor it and so until they do i'm
sorry i can't give them free advertising
from daniel hey michael if if as per
current feminist ideology sex work is
work uh would it then be safe to extend
that logic to it being okay to require
workers to
to perform sexual favors as part of the
job description i don't think the
feminists will like where this leads yes
feminism began with
hey it's not right to sleep with your
secretary to um hey
it's
sl sleeping with people is real work to
now like hey you better sleep with your
secretary that's real work man if that's
where feminism went then by golly
feminism is the greatest trick that men
have ever played on women i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
see on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin